So, with any row of five, at the end
of round two, every processor has heard from every
other processor in the entire system. Right? So you
can eyeball this figure and see that every processor
has gotten the message from every other processor, and
so it's common knowledge that for every processor that
every one else has also arrived. Add the barrier.
So, how many rounds does it take to know that
everybody has arrived at the barrier? Well its ceiling
of log N to the base two. You add the
ceiling because it's N need not be a part of
two. So at this point, everybody is awake. So, barrier
completion here there is no distinction between arrival and
wake up as you, as you saw. In the case
of the tree barrier or the MCS barrier or the
tournament barrier. In the dissemination barrier, because it is happening
by information diffusion, at the end of a ceiling of log n rounds, everybody
has heard from everyone else in the
entire system So everyone knows that that barrier
has been breached. So in other words,
in every zone of communication in the dissemination
barrier, every processor, you eyeball any particular
processor. Every processor is receiving exactly one message,
exactly one message in every round of the
dissemination barrier. So overall During the entire dissemination barrier
information diffusion that's going on, every processor is receiving
a total of a ceiling of log n to
the base two messages. Every round one message,
and so they are ceiling of log n rounds
and so a ceiling of log n to the base two is a number of messages that any
given processor is receiving and once. Every processor
has received this ceil N log to the base
2 number of messages. It knows that the
barrier is complete. It can move on. And I've
been using the word message in describing this
dissemination barrier. It's convenient to do, to use that
word because it is information diffusion but if you
think about a shared memory machine, a message is
basically a spin locatoin. And, once again because
I know an ordained processor is going to
talk to me in every round, the spin
location for this guy is statically determined. Spin
location, statically determined, and so on. So every
round of the tournament, we can statically determine
the spin location that a particular processor has
to wait on, in order to receive a message.
Which is really a signal from its ordained
peer, for that particular round of the dissemination
barrier. So, again static determination of spin location
becomes extremely important if the multiprocessor happens to be
an NCC NUMA machine. In that case, what you want to do is to locate the
spin location. In the memory that is closest
to the particular processor. So that becomes more efficient.
And as always, in every one of these barried algorithms, you
have to do sense reversal. That once this barrier is complete,
everybody is going on to, to the next phase of the
competition. And when they go to the next phase of the competition.
They have to make sure that the barrier that they arrive
is the next barrier. So you need sense reversal then, it needs
to happen at the end of. Everybody algorithm. So now let's
talk about some of the virtues of the dissemination barrier. The first
thing that you'll notice is in the structure, there
is no hierarchy. In the tree algorithms, the root
of the tree automatically gives you a hierarchy in
terms of The organization of the tree in the
dissemination barrier, there's no such thing. And I already
mentioned that this algorithm works for both NCC NUMA
machine, as well as clusters. That's also a good
thing. And there is no waiting on anybody else.
So every processor is independently making a decision to send
a message. As soon as it arrives at the barrier.
Is ready to send a message to its peer for
that particular round. And of course, every processor can move to
the next round only after it has received a corresponding
message from its peer for this particular round. So as
soon as that happens, it can move on to the
next round of the dissemination barrier. And all the processes will
realize that the barrier is complete when they
received Ceil (Log N) messages in the entire
structure of this organism. So if you think
about the total amount of communication, because the
communication in every round is fixed, it's N
messages in every round and since there are
Ceil (Log N) rounds, the communication complexity. Of
this algorithm is order and log in. Compare that
to the communication complexity of the tournament, or
the the Tree barrier. In both of those cases,
the communication complexity was only log in, because of
the hierarchy, as you go toward the root of
the tree, the amount of communication shrinks, so. The
amount of communication in those algorithms is only order
of log N. Where as, in this, this simulation
down here, since there is no hierarchy, the total
amount of communication in the, algorathim is order of analog N.